근데 우리나라 정유회사들의 장점이 하나 있습니다.
다 유종을 처리할 수 있는 역량이 있어요.
중진류, 경진류 뭐든 간에 갖다만 주세요.
저희가 정지합니다. 이게 돼요.
왜 다 잘하냐고.
그러니까요.
우리나라가 왜 다 잘하는지 알아요?
왜요?
아무것도 없었어요.
중진류에서 나오는 어떤 그런 석유 부산물들에 대해서 한국이 짱이다.
맞습니다.
그래서 오이다.
진짜로?
이런 말을 적고 있습니다.
맞습니다.
그 부산물까지 우리는 그것까지 또 끌고 모아서 그걸 가지고 또 파는 기술.
아껴야죠.
우리 나라는 껍질이 얼마 주고 수입해야 하는데.
하나 받아.
많은 수건을 쟤한테 싸야지. 껍질에서.
안녕하세요.
박정우 교수님 어서 오십시오.
다들 벌써 댓글에서 다 박 교수도 용서받으셨나요? 라고 물어보시는데.
그게 제일 궁금하긴 해.
요즘에 너무 좋으시대요.
니뉴는 차 보러 다니고 교수님은 집 보러 다니고 이런 소문이 사방에.
저도 용서를 받고 나서 일단 다른 것보다도 멘탈 케어가 됐다는 거예요.
여유가 있어.
좋아 보이십니다.
안경도 바꾸셨네요.
제가 장만했습니다.
독일제 안경 아니야?
시계도 이거 좀 범점처럼 시계 가리시면 안 돼요?
오늘은 사실 박 교수님께 여쭤보려다가 최근에 또 중돈 관련해가지고.
주제는 중돈입니까?
아무거나 여쭤봐도 되는데.
저한테도 기회를 주시겠습니까?
기회를 주시면 중돈이기도 하고 싶었습니다.
저는 여러 방송에서 제가 한 가지 기억하셔야 될 게 주식시장 좋은데 고춧가루 뿌리는 소리는 아닙니다.
오해하지 마시고요.
아니 이거 휴전 종전 쉽지 않다 여러 번 얘기를 드렸는데 뭐 그때마다 이거 녹화 방송 아니냐 도대체 내일 휴전 협상 들어가는데 이거 언제쯤 방송 떠 놓은 거냐 이러시는데 저 요즘은 바로바로 녹화를 하거든요.
그런데 진짜 이게 쉽지가 않습니다.
왜 그런지 그거부터 설명을 좀 드릴게요.
이제 슬슬 우리가 모니터를 쳐다보면서 관리를 할 때가 됐다 이렇게 생각을 합니다.
왜요?
이거 솔직히 지표상으로는 과열이 맞아요.
지표상으로 과열이 맞습니다.
저는 개인적으로 주식시장이 과열인지 아닌지를 알아보기 위해서 9개 지표를 돌려보고요.
그게 만약에 혼조세로 시그널이 다르면 6개 정도나 5개를 더 돌립니다.
그런데 최근에는 9개 모두 과열이 심하다라는 지표로 나왔어요.
대표적으로 버핏지수, 실러지수 여러 가지 있지 않습니까?
이 많은 걸 했더니 과열은 맞아요.
그런데 대표적으로 실러지수를 바탕으로 얘기하면 예전에 2013년에도 심한 과열이라고 나왔지만 그 뒤에 7년 동안 주식시장에 상승했어요.
그러니까 이 지표는 그냥 참고용인데 그래도 우리가 항상 돌다리도 두들겨 보고 해야지.
자칫 잘못하면 저처럼 한 2년 묶였다가 간신히 찾을 수가 있거든요.
용서해주세요.
용서 받지 못한 자가 됐으니까.
그럼요.
그래서 이제는 좀 우리가 주의를 기울이면서 쳐다봐야 되는데 또 과열이라고 제가 확신하는 또 다른 이유가 사실 전쟁이 안 끝나고 더욱더 유가 수급에 대해서 어려움이 야기될 가능성도 있음에도 불구하고 연일 다 잔치해요.
관심이 없어요.
관심이 없어.
유가가 뭐 막혔나?
그래서 제가 동해에서 기름나기 시작했나 싶기도 하고 아무도 관심이 없는 거예요.
그런데 이 생각보다 중동발 악재는 오래 갑니다.
자 그거를 복잡한 얘기 안 하고 아주 쉽게 설명드릴게요.
20세기 이후에 모든 전쟁의 마지막 장면은 다 똑같습니다.
뭘까요?
어떻게 끝났을까요?
압수하면서?
비슷합니다.
바로 뭐냐 하면 큰 회의 테이블에 문서를 놓고 양 국가를 대표하는 사람이 사인해야 끝나요.
그게 휴전이든 종전이든 정전이든 간에 일단 사인을 해야 끝나는데.
그러면 그 구성 요건이 지금 완비되어 있는지를 보면 이란 전쟁이 일단락이 될 건지 안 될 건지를 확인할 수 있잖아요.
그런데 그 요건이 너무나도 하나도 정해진 게 없어요.
예를 들어서 이란 같은 경우는 그 회의 테이블에 그 사인할 때 누가 나갈 겁니까?
그래 누군 누가 대표인데.
그러니까요.
하메네이 돌아가셨고 둘째 아들이 차기 지도자라고 선정될 때지만 안 나타나고 있잖아요.
맞아요.
하메네이 때는 하메네이가 혁명수비대뿐만 아니라 일반적인 거버넌스, 양쪽 축을 자기가 혼자 총괄하고 있었거든요.
그런데 이 사람이 사라졌어요.
그래서 혁명수비대와 거버넌스가 지금 각각 달리 움직여요.
그러면 예를 들어서 의회의장이라든가 대통령이 가서 사인한다고 하면 혁명수비대가 뭐라고 할까요?
네가 뭔데 가서 사인을 해?
이렇게 된단 말이에요.
그리고 혁명수비대가 가서 사인한다고 하면 대통령이 네가 뭔데 이렇게 되는 거예요.
그럼 도대체 이 회의 테이블에 나가야 하나요?
회의 테이블에 나갈 사람은 누군데 누가 나가서 사인해도 반은 동의 안 하는 사인은 의미 없는 거잖아요.
결국 계속 전쟁하겠죠.
구심점이 사라진 상황에서 구심점 역할을 누가 대신할 건지 회의 테이블에 나갈 대표성이 있는 사람도 잘 안 정해진 상황이에요.
그럼 그거 하나가 안 정해졌고.
그다음 두 번째 그럼 회의 테이블에 나갈 국가들은 어디냐도 중요한 거예요.
이란하고 미국만 이번 전쟁하고 있습니까? 아니잖아요.
이스라엘.
그러면 이란과 미국이 사인한 건 이스라엘이 무조건 동의하는 겁니까?
안 해가지고 지난번에도 휴전 협상하는데 헤즈블라 세력들 자기네들이 단죄하겠다고 레바논 계속 공격하고 있었잖아요.
이스라엘은 거기 들어가는 건지 안 들어가는 건지 아니면 이스라엘은 무조건 동의하기로 한 건지 그것도 안 정해졌어요.
아유 노답이다 진짜.
그러니까요.
그다음에 더 중요한 게 있습니다.
이런 마지막 종전이든 휴전이든 정전을 할 때 그 문서.
그 문서의 내용을 조율하는 것도 중요하지만.
네.
그 문서대로 그러면 상대방이 지켜줄 건지 그 신뢰가 제일 중요해요.
그런데 이미 트럼프라는 협상의 대상자는 그 신뢰를 너무나도 잃었어요.
왜냐하면 이란 입장에선 오바마 대통령 때 약속했던 핵합의 다 약속을 했는데 그건 오바마랑 약속한 게 아니라 마침 그때 미국의 대표가 오바마였던 거예요.
그냥 미국과 약속을 한 겁니다.
그런데 오바마 퇴임하고 트럼프가 들어서더니 야 그거 오바마가 한 거 아니야.
찢어.
찢었단 말이에요.
그리고 나서 다시 협상하자고 얘기했는데 협상 기한 데드라인이 이틀 남았는데 이번에 이란 전쟁을 미국이 먼저 감행했던 거고.
그리고 지금 와서 요구하는 게 그럼 옛날에 얘기했던 거와 크게 다른 거냐.
아니에요.
옛날에 핵합의 내용에서 그게 벗어나는 것도 별로 없어요.
그러면 도대체 얘가 이번에 또 사인하자고 한 걸 우리가 믿고 사인하고 그냥 여기서 전쟁 그만두면 되는 거냐.
그 신뢰가 벌써 망가진 상태예요.
그러니 이거는 마지막 장면 연출하는.
그렇죠.
그 장면의 구성 요소들 체크 리스트들 중에서 뭐 하나도 지금 구성된 게 없는 거예요.
우크라이나 전쟁도 몇 년씩 하듯이 이것도 장기화될 가능성은.
그럴 가능성이 많아요.
그러면 어떻게 되느냐.
이야 이제는 모든 해협에서 다 흥행을 받기 시작하고 그러면 이게 물가는 얼마까지 또 반영이 될지.
걱정되는 부분이 유가가 생각보다 그렇게 많이 떨어지고 있지는 않다.
맞습니다.
원유.
LNG.
LNG가 다시 공급망에도 굉장히 영향이 있잖아요.
있죠.
사실 그래서 지금 미국인들이 우리 니뉘님 소식을 들었는지 모르겠습니다만 일부가 한국 증시를 쳐다보기 시작했어요.
그래.
니들이 와야지 안 오고 뵐게요.
왜?
왜냐.
바로 미국도 우리에게 석유를 수입하고 있는 나라거든요.
아.
한국유 그거요?
맞습니다.
사실 우리나라의 1등 수출폰모품을 우리 다 알죠.
반도체.
2등 뭡니까?
2등 자동차.
아닙니다.
편의점.
아.
반납이 돼요.
네.
아닙니다. 저도 자동차라고 생각했던 적이 있었어요. 그런데 통상적으로 석유 제품과 석유화학 제품 유입니다. 즉 원유는 아무 의미가 없잖아요. 원유를 정제해서 휘발유, 항공유, 경유 이런 걸로 정제해서 팔고 이걸 기반으로 석유화학 제품 유를 파는 게 우리 두 번째 수출 품목인데
그런데 캘리포니아 지역 같은 경우는 우리나라에서 정제한 항공유라든가 휘발유를 갖다 쓰고 있었거든요.
그랬어요?
그러니까 캘리포니아는 우리 걸 갖다 쓰고 있었어요.
흥부석유 거를?
우리나라가 세계 4위의 석유 수입국인데 그게 우리가 석유를 흥청망청 써서 그런 게 아니라
우리가 그렇게 석유를 많이 수입하다가 다 석유 플랜트 시설에서 정제해서 다시 갖다 팔아서
우리가 세계 정유 사업 규모로는 5위에 속합니다.
그런데 이 5위가 우리보다 높은 국가들 보면요.
중국, 예를 들어 러시아, 미국 이렇게 원래 석유 갖다 팔아야 되는 나라들이 좀 있고
그 다음에 인도, 그 다음에 우리 한국이에요.
한국이 호르무즈에서 석유를 못 가져서 우리 캘리포니아에서 항공유라든가 기타 석유류를 수급받기 어려워지는 거 아니야?
이 생각 때문에 벌써 캘리포니아 지역에서는 항공유 가격이 20% 이상 올랐어요.
그래서 이렇다면 이쪽 지역의 정유회사들도 관심을 둬야겠네? 하면서 쳐다보고 있는 사람도 있어요.
와, 웅장해진다.
아니, 근데 사실 교수님 저는 석유도 석유인데 LNG 투자를 좀 하고 있거든요.
LNG를?
LNG 투자를 해요?
네.
어떻게 보세요?
아니, 뭐 투자 안 하는 건 뭐예요?
아니, 왜냐하면 석유를 호르무즈에 막히면 LNG 뚫어서 그래서 철관도 만들고 가스로 어떻게 해야 되는 거 아니야?
자네는 회사원이잖아요.
아니, 나랑 걱정해야지.
전문 투자자보다 더 많이 투자를 하는 것 같아.
요즘 LNG도 중요한 얘기 해주셨습니다.
요즘 이것 때문에 또 주목받고 있는 회사. 회사 얘기해도 되는 거예요?
아, 예, 예.
주목받고 있다는 얘기입니다.
회사원입니다. 교수님이 갈 뿐이지 제가 가는 건 아니니까.
저 처음 들었죠, 지금.
SK 이노베이션입니다.
사실 호르무즈는 이제 원유보다도 천연가스 수급 때문에 중요한 곳이에요.
거의 카타르가 있거든요.
세계에서 천연가스 가장 많이 수출하는 곳.
그런데 이 천연가스가 거기서 못 나오는 게 더 큰 문제예요.
전 세계에서 원유를 수급받을 수 있는 국가는 많아요.
우리가 산유국으로 분류할 수 있는 나라는 120여 개국이 되다 보니
굳이 찾으려면 찾을 수는 있습니다.
그런데 천연가스는 카타르의 비중이 너무 크거든요.
그런데 카타르에서 LNG를 받아올 수가 없는 상황이니 이거 난리가 났단 말이에요.
그래서 이거 어떻게 하면 좋냐 했더니
마침 우리나라 같은 경우는 SK 이노베이션이 호주에 LNG 광산에 지분 투자를 해놨고
그래서 그 LNG 광산에서
천연가스를 추출해서 우리나라 서해 앞바다로 가져와서 국내에 수급을 해주고 있어요.
그렇기 때문에 우리가 거기만 쳐다볼 게 아니라
다른 데서도 LNG를 가져올 수 있는 루트를 확보하는 정유회사가 있구나.
이게 확인된 거죠.
그래서 주목을 받고 있는 것이고
그러다 보니까 이 전쟁이 조금 길어지면 에너지와 관련된 밸류체인들이 슬슬 재편이 될 거거든요.
그런데 우리나라 정유회사들의 장점이 하나 있습니다.
다 유종을 처리할 수 있는 역량이 있어요.
다 유종.
중진류, 경진류.
그리고 뭐든 간에 갖다만 주세요.
저희가 정지합니다.
이게 돼요.
왜 다 잘하냐고.
그러니까요.
우리나라가 왜 다 잘하는지 알아요?
왜요?
아무것도 없었어요.
실패한 거 다 해야지.
우리가 그 중에 하나만 나오면 그거만 하겠죠.
아무것도 없으니까 다 잘해야 돼.
다시 정리하겠습니다.
저는 SK 대주주 아닙니다, 이노베이션.
제가 대주주면 여기를 왜 나옵니까?
여기가 어때서?
제가 여기를 왜 나옵니까?
그래서 정리하자면 SK 이노베이션 말씀 주셨으니까 그걸 가지고 말씀드리면
일단 다 품종을 처리할 수 있는 역량이 있고 LNG도 자체적으로 광산이라고 하면 안 되고 지분을 가지고 있어서 수급을 할 수 있는 곳도 가지고 있고
그리고 심지어 SK 이노베이션에서 석유를 갖다 쓰는 게 우리나라만 해당되는 게 아니라 여러 국가들이 거기서 석유를 갖다 쓰고 있는 심지어 미국까지도
그러니까 바로 한국 기업들에 대한 관심도가 높아지고 있고 그래서 요즘은 뭘 더 걱정하는 나라들이 생겼냐면요.
베트남이나 베트남.
필리핀이나 일부 나라들은 호르무주가 중요한 게 아니라 우리는 정확히 말하면 한국에서 석유를 갖다 쓰는데
이 한국이 이러다가 이거 본인들 석유 모자른다고 우리도 안 주는 거 아니야? 이런 걱정을 하고 있어요.
이런 일이 일어난다.
우리 상유국이었던 거예요.
IMF 이후에 전 세계 인프라를 향해서 진짜 가시는 우리 선배님들이 있었기에 진짜 다 그거 한 수 앞을 몇 수 앞을 보시고 이렇게 다 세팅을 다 해놓으신 거잖아요.
비록 당군 할아버지가 터는 잘못 잡았지만
네.
우리가 열심히 선배님들이 해주셔가지고 우리가 주식을 이렇게 또 실천을 바라볼 수 있게 되지 않았을까.
갑자기?
한국을 사랑하니까.
제가 알기에 교수님.
우리나라가 중동에서 수입하는데 중동이 아무래도 중진류다 보니까 중진류를 수입해서 가공해서 파는 대표적인 나라여서 중진류에서 나오는 어떤 그런 석유 부산물들에 대해서 한국이 짱이다.
맞습니다.
그래서 5위다.
진짜로?
이런 말을 들었거든요.
맞습니다.
그 부산물까지 우리는 또 이런 거 있죠.
그것까지 또 끌고 모아서 그걸 가지고 또 파는 기술.
아껴야죠.
껍질 얼마 주고 수입해야 하는데.
맞아.
하나, 하나, 하나.
많은 수건에서 젤라틴 짜야지.
껍질에서.
많은 수건을 쥐어 짜는 능력.
이걸 우리가 가지고 있습니다.
아니 근데 사실 이 에너지가 막히고 하는 걸 보면서 미국도 막 트럼프가 엄청 우리 비상이다.
막 전력을 확보해야 된다 하지만 중국도 사실 수입을 하는데 어마어마한 영향이 있지 않습니까?
맞습니다.
막히면 중국도 힘들 것 같은데.
맞아요.
사실 그래서 이번에 사실 휴전이나 종전을 어떻게 보면 중재하고 있는 게 사실 파키스탄이 아닙니다.
파키스탄 뒤에 중국이 있어요.
자, 성 설명을 좀 드리면 중국은 지금 중국 경제를 떠받치고 있는 굉장히 중요한 요인들 그중에 하나가 제재유입니다.
제재유.
국제적으로 미국이 금융 제재를 해서 국제 시장에서 원유를 제값을 받고 제대로 팔 수 없는 그런 석유를 제재유라 부르는데
그 제재유 중에서 베네수엘라 이거 미국이 점거했고요.
근데 원래 이 베네수엘라 석유를 중국이 사갔고요.
또 이란 석유의 90%를 중국이 사갔습니다.
근데 이것도 제재유거든요.
그리고 원래 러시아도 제재유였어요.
얼마 전까지.
자, 그래서 이 제재유들 통상적으로 국제 시세에 비해서 20% 가까이 가격이 싼데 그 값싼 석유를 들여와서 본인들 생활물가 에너지 물가 낮추고 제품 가격 경쟁력 높이는데 이 제재유들을 현격히 활용해왔던 게 중국입니다.
갑자기 이란 원유가 차단되고 베네수엘라 원유가 차단되고 그러니 중국이 지금 난리가 난 거예요.
이 제재유 수급이 어려워져서.
특히 이 제재유는 중국의 산둥 지방에서 주로 정제를 하거든요.
그래서 중국의 산둥 지방을 제재 원유의 무덤이라고 부릅니다.
그런데 만약에 이게 길어지면 산둥 지방부터 원유 수급이 안 돼서 이제 공장이 올스톱 되는 회사들이 즐비하게 생길 거 아니에요.
그래서 중국도 지금 발등에 불이 떨어졌습니다.
전쟁이 길어지면 안 되니까요.
그래서 비축분까지 다 소요되고.
비축분이 소진되고 나면 문제가 심각해질 거 같으니 중국이 원래 본인이 휴전이나 종전 또는 정전을 중재해야 되는데
그러면 트럼프가 할 휴전도 하겠습니까?
아, 그렇지. 중국이 끼면 또 못 참지.
중국이 중재한 거를 미국이 수용했다? 이 꼴은 또 못 보죠.
그렇지. 그거 못 보지.
그럼요. 그래서 중국이 예전 같았으면
야, 미국 이리 와 봐. 이란 이리 와 봐. 내가 중재해 줄게 하면서
본인의 국제적인 리더십을 한껏 올리는데 이걸 활용했을 텐데요.
이번에는 본인도 급한 거예요.
그래서 뒤로 숨고 이란하고 중국은 아주 돈독한 사이고 파키스탄하고 중국은 거의 베스트 프렌이에요.
그래서 어떻게 했느냐. 야, 이란. 이번 휴전안이나 종전안을 내가 보증 쓸게. 그러니 일단 협상을 해 봐.
그리고 파키스탄. 내가 나설 수 없어. 네가 전면에 나서서 얘네 둘을 중재해라. 이렇게 된 거예요.
꼭두각시.
그렇죠. 그러다 보니까 중국이 워낙 급하다 보니 이걸 뒤에서 지금 해결해야 되는데.
지금 해결을 하려고 하는 것이지. 지금 중국도 원유 수급에 빨간불이 켜진 것은 분명한 사실입니다. 비축분이 있을 뿐이죠.
그럼 교수님. 지금 어떻게 진행이 되고 있는 거예요? 도대체 이놈의 전쟁이.
이게 어디까지 갔어요? 이게 휴전이 될 거예요? 안 될 거예요? 누가 어디서 막히고? 지금 뭔 상황입니까?
지금은 이제 자존심 싸움이 된 거예요. 일단 트럼프는 예전에는 셀프 종전 휴전이라고 하죠.
내가 이겼어. 휴전하고 그냥 빼려고 했는데.
그것도 쉽게 안 되게 됐어요. 그리고 이란도 국민들이 다시 자신감이 생겼어요.
이거 봐. 미국이 계속 휴전 연장을 하고 계속 뭔가를 해주면서 우리한테 뭘 이끌어내려고 하네. 얘네들이 지금 해결을 못 보고 있네.
되네?
되네? 이 자신감이 생겼어요. 그래서 트럼프가 결국 선택한 것은 중국 옆구리 찌르기예요.
어떻게 해요?
원래 그동안 호르무즈 해협이 봉쇄는 됐지만 중국 배들은 간간히 이란이 빼줬거든요.
야, 너희들은 나가. 했었잖아요.
위안화로 결제했다고.
네. 위안화로 결제했다고. 너희들은 나가. 이거거든요.
그게 위안화로 결제한 배는 나가도 좋다는 게 사실상 중국 배는 나가도 된다는 얘기가 다른 편이잖아요.
그런데 가만히 보니까 지금 트럼프가 중국도 지금 마음이 급하네? 확인을 한 거예요.
그래서 본인 역으로 나도 그럼 봉쇄할 거야 하면서 본인이 호르무즈 뚫으라고 했던 사람이 본인이 봉쇄하면서 중국 배마저도 못 나가게 한 거죠.
그럼 뭐다? 야, 중국 네가 좀 해결을 해. 를 뒤에서 지금 푸시하고 있는 겁니다.
아, 밀당 진짜 쩐다.
그래서 지금 국제정세가 체스판에 장군이요, 그럼 멍군이요 이렇게 하고 있는 거예요.
그랬더니 또 중국도 열받은 거예요. 자기는 해결을 하려고 했는데 저놈이 호르무즈 해협을 나까지 봉쇄를 해?
그래서 지난주인가요 중국이 황산 수출을 통제하기 시작했어요.
이 황산은 워낙 다방면에 쓰이는 뭐랄까 산업재해인데.
그 중에 일부는 농산물에도 쓰입니다.
그래서 이게 봉쇄되면 미국 공화당의 텃밭이라고 할 수 있는 중남부 대규모 농가들에게 치명상을 줘요.
어, 거기 마가들도 많잖아요.
그렇죠. 그래서 시진핑이 다시 황산 출하를 좀 줄이면서 트럼프한테 다시 외통수를 던진 거예요.
대박이다.
그래서 지금 외신에서 막 나오는 수많은 내용들이 제가 보기에는 딱 한 수 두니까 또 멍군이요 하고 이러고 있는 상황이다.
이렇게 보시면 되겠습니다.
요즘 많은 분들이 의구심을 가지고 있었던 거 있었죠.
바로 금.
금. 네.
아니 전쟁이 터졌는데 금 가격이 계속 떨어졌었어요.
맞아요. 이상했어.
그러다가 최근 들어서 조금 반등하기 시작했습니다.
이게 사실 러시아와 관련된 거예요.
설명을 좀 드릴게요.
원래 작년에 트럼프의 골머리를 썩게 만든 건 인도의 모리총리입니다.
왜냐하면 이 모리가 러시아산 석유 사지 말라고 했는데 인도가 업무가 없어서.
네.
인도가 엄청 사줬잖아요.
맞아. 맞아. 맞아.
그래서 인도가 러시아 석유를 사주는 바람에 러시아는 그걸로 군자금 마련해서 전쟁을 하고 있었는데 트럼프가 야 모리 정말 이제 그만 좀 사.
너희 왜 그러니 그랬더니 모리가 싫어.
나 러시아에서 석유 싸게 사서 그래서 물건 만들어서 미국에 수출해서 돈 벌 거야 한 거죠.
그래서 트럼프가 어떻게 했습니까.
작년에 인도에 가장 센 관세율을 부과했던 나라 중에 하나가 인도예요.
아.
그래? 알았어.
그럼 나도 너 관세 엄청 부과할 거야 한 거예요.
그런데 모리가 한 3, 4개월 만에 백기투항을 합니다.
알았어. 알았어. 관세 풀어줘. 내 러시아산 석유 더 이상 안 살게 한 거예요.
그래서 그래 사지 마 하고 관세 낮춰주고 그리고 인도는 러시아산 석유를 안 사기로 했어요.
그럼 문제가 된 게 누구입니까. 러시아죠.
러시아.
러시아는 석유 팔아서 군자금 조달했는데 석유를 못 팔게 된 거예요. 그래서 러시아에서 조사를 해봤죠.
그런데 러시아는 참 저도 출장 갈 때마다 부러웠던 게 정말 농담이 아니고 과장이 아닙니다.
네.
원소 주기율 표상에 있는 모든 광물을 다 가지고 있는 나라가 러시아예요.
땅이 넓으니까.
땅이 넓으니까. 그것도 매장량이 세계 5위 안에 대부분이 들어요.
그래서 러시아가 결정을 합니다. 야. 지금 석유를 못 팔게 됐어. 안 되겠다. 야. 금광 광산 풀리 돌려.
그래서 금을 그냥 벌크로 캐서 해외 금을 연락 수출한 거예요.
대박.
그러면서 국제 금 시세가 떨어지기 시작한 거예요.
와.
그래서 계속 러시아에서 금 공급을 계속하니까 떨어지다가 갑자기 국제사회에서 트럼프한테 야. 트럼프 네가 괜히 이란 건드려서 호르몬즈가 막혔어.
너 이거 석유 가격 어떻게 할 거야 했더니 트럼프가 푸틴에게 전화를 해서 야. 푸틴 너 석유 수출 금지한 거 내가 풀어줄 테니까 다시 석유 팔아 한 거예요.
그랬더니 푸틴이 어떻게 했다. 야. 석유 다시 팔 수 있게 됐다. 금광 광산 올 수도.
수도.
그러면서 금 가격이 다시 조금 오른 거예요.
와. 대박.
이런 여러 변화가 있었던 거예요.
자 그래서 지금은 연준의 기준금리 쳐다보고 있을 때가 아닙니다.
기준금리가 문제가 아니야.
지금 경제를 결정하는 가장 중요한 변수는 이 체스판의 장군이여 먼 군이여 장군이여 먼 군이여 이거예요.
진짜 대박이다. 따라가기가 너무 힘드니까.
힘들어요.
그러면 말씀을 들어보니까.
대박. 대박.
뭐 빨리 끝날 것 같지는 않고.
제가요. 제가 봐도 그래요.
그러니까.
그래서 여러분.
네.
오늘의 결론입니다.
오늘 다른 것도 하겠지만.
네.
일단 주식시장 앞으로 더 갈 것 같습니다.
그렇지만 지표상에 과열이 떴을 때는 우리 이제 돌다리도 이렇게 두들겨 보면서 가셔야지.
안 그러면 저처럼 2차전지 제가 너무 쉽게 생각했다가 간신히 탈출한 거 아시잖아요.
그렇죠.
그렇게 될 수 있으니 앞으로 신중한 투자 조금 권고해 드립니다.
체스판에 놓다 놓는다는 말은 예측이 안 된다는 말인가요.
그렇죠. 맞습니다.
그렇지.
그리고 이제는 분명한 건 있죠.
네.
우리는 주식시장 애정을 갖기 시작했어요.
맞아. 공부하기 시작했어요.
우리가.
그리고 이제는 어느 전문가가 나와서 주식시장 떨어질 것 같습니다. 고점일 것 같습니다. 하면 댓글이 그 놈 죽여라. 죽여라. 하면서. 그렇기 때문에.
그런데 오늘 박 교수님이 과열이라고 하지 않았습니까.
그래도 간다고 할 수도 있습니다.
그래도 간다고 했어요?
간다고 얘기했어요.
과열이라고 얘기한 것 같은데.
갑니다.
간다고요?
과열이 있는데도 간다?
네.
그런데 체스판만 적용이 안 되는 거죠.
사실 우리 현생이 너무 바빠서. 맨날 뭐가 업데이트가 되니까.
그러면 우리가 딱 어디 산업에 투자를.
결국 종목물을 보고 있어.
아니. 우리가 현생이 바쁘니까. 투자자들이.
그러면 교수님은 과열인 것 같고. 체스판이 어지러운 것 같으니까. 혹시 조금 줄이고 계시는.
네.
역시.
그러면 제가
네.
그럼 저한테 더.
굳이 굳이.
전혀요 아 전혀 말과 행동이 좀 다르신거 아닙니까 계좌는 풀롱 아니에요 계좌는 풀롱이어서
저에 대해서 많은 분들이 평화한게 딱 맞아요 얼굴이 과열이다 과열되어 있습니다 저도 정리를 해드릴게요
자 지금은 엄청난 쏠림 현상이 있어요 그리고 지금은 주도주와 그렇지 않은 주의 희비가 분명히 엇갈리고 있습니다
그래서 지금은 달리는 말 중심에 올라타야지 주변부에 가있으면 안됩니다 그래서 이렇게 하셔야 돼요 진짜 ai니 우리 늘 듣던 얘기 있잖아요
아 그건 나도 알고 다른거 뭐 없어요 그러시면 안돼요 지금은 중심이 달리고 있기 때문에 그 중심에 같이 있어야지
돈들이 들어오니까 특히 돈 들어오는게 이제는 etf 형태로 많이 들어오지 않습니까 그럼 etf는 몰빵이 안되잖아요
맞아요 포트를 짜줘야 되니까 맞아요
그래서 포트를 짜다 짜다 어쩔 수 없이 죄송한 표현입니다만 다른 업종 아 이정도 호재해가지고 예전에 안올랐는데 까지도 올라가는거에요
가장 본질 실적과 미래를 그려가고 있는 그 본질에 해당되는거는 그건 앞으로도 더 갈수가 있어요
그리고 그거는 외인들도 한국에 또 돈을 넣을거구요 그러니 결국 어느 순간 외인들이 돌아왔을때 주도주에 당연히 넣지
그 변주기 안넣거든요 그러면 한번 더 뻥 하고 갈 수 있는 그걸 하셔야지
그렇죠 그렇죠 그러면 한번 더 뻥하고 갈 수 있는 그걸 하셔야지
그러면 한번 더 뻥하고 갈 수 있는 그걸 하셔야지
지금 어디도 올랏대 뭐도 올랏대 야 이것도 올랏대 그럴거 할 때가 아니에요
자 그리고 또 하나 쏠림 현상이 생긴 이유가 바로 이 유튜브 때문입니다
이제는 이게 나쁘다는게 아니에요 모든 사람들이 워낙 좋은 유튜브 컨텐츠들도 많고 채널도 많기 때문에 안보고 싶어도 알고리즘 막 추천을 해줘요
요즘 개인들이 더 똑똑해요 맞아요 진짜 개인들이 더 똑똑하세요
애널리스트님이 한마디 하면 그거 아닌데요 그거 아닌데 맞아요 저도 축하를 하기 힘들어요
힘들어 그니까 진짜 힘들겠어 진짜 힘들어 이제 먹고살기 힘들어 별소리도 다 들어요 지금
자 그래서 바로 이런 일들이 있기 때문에 어떤 일이 생겼다 야 뭐 좋다더라 하면 다들 같이 태웁니다
그래서 올라갈때 쭉쭉쭉쭉 가요 자 그래서 많은 사람들이 알고있는건 쭉쭉쭉 가는데 모르는거는 그 사람 설득하고 이해시키고 그 종목에 대한 주의 환기시키는데도 기간이 걸리겠죠
그 사이에 다른건 더 날라가는데 그러니 지금은
남들이 모르는거 내가 발굴했다 나도 이거 찾았다 이런거 하지 마시고 달리는 말 등에 올라타세요
그럼 요즘에 주식시장이 이렇게 좋으면 부동산도 반도체로도 돈이 많이 들어온다 그러고 우리나라 자산시장 전체가 좀 나쁘진 않겠네요
뭐 사실 그런 면이 있죠 부동산시장이 각종 규제를 더 덧대서 어떻게든 시장을 안정화시키고 싶은 욕구가 있는데 좀 안타깝게도 주식으로 돈 번 사람들이 다시 부동산으로 가고 있어요
그런데 이제는 다주택자들은 확실히 그만해라 다주택은 하지마라 했잖아요 그래서 요즘 노른자위 지역에 상가 매물 나오면 24시간 안되서 다 나갑니다
그러니까 돈을 미리 누가 놔두고 갔나봐요 자산가들 같은 경우는 뭐 몇백억이든 뭐 이렇게 있는 사람들이 주식회사에서 또 돈이 잔뜩 생긴거에요
또 하이닉스도 또 벌었어 또 벌었어 그런데 그걸 돈에 주식시장에 또 넣는건 우리 좀전에 하고 갔던 우리 박팀장님 같은 분이 주식에 또 넣는거고
이미 주식시장에도 너무 많은걸 넣으신 분은 이거 일부 빼서 부동산을 그동안 샀는데 그동안 꼬마빌딩도 샀고 집도 몇개 샀고 했는데 그거 하지 말라고 했잖아요
그러니 방법은 여기는 상가가 도저히 공실날 것 같지 않는 노른자위 상가 그래서 임대소득이 빵빵하게 나올 것 같은 상황이에요
같은 상가 그런데 그냥 돈 미리 근처 복덕방에 돈 넣어놓고 그거 나오면 이걸로 계산 좀 해줘 이렇게 해서 24시간도 안되서 상가 다 나가요
그러니까 지금 여기 스튜디오가 좁고 그래서 스튜디오 있는데를 좀 구하고 있거든요 이게 잘 안돼요
안돼요
그 걱정이 많습니다 그래서 어떻게 되는지
슈카는 이제 하나 올려야죠
뭘 올려요 뭘 올려
언제까지 전자야
올려줘
알았지 이제 매말로 봐야지
우리 슈카처럼 이 큰 여기이신 분들 못보시는데
이제 스튜디오 좋아요
한 2만평 되죠 이 스튜디오가
풍경 좋다 여기 메아리 돌립니다
피디님 들리세요
전화로 하세요 피디님한테 얘기하고 있으면
진짜 요즘 다시 또 주식으로 돈 버는 사람들은 부동산에 일단 주택은 못사니까 다른 형태로 사는 사람들이 늘기 시작했다 이렇게 보시면 되겠습니다
좋습니다
자 그러면은 저희가 스튜디오를 만들 때 꼬마 빌딩으로 들어가는게 좋습니까
아 이 상가 어디 그런거 구해서
거기 그런거 구해서
찐상담이야 이거
개인상담
드디어 슈카 본색을 나타낸 꼬마 빌딩
아니 우리 스튜디오 자리가 없어요 지금
개인상담
두기세력
두기세력 이야기야 지금
적폐
무슨 소리야 내가 내 쓰는거 들어간다는데
나쁜걸 알려드려요 좋은걸 알려드려요
우와
좋은거
아 순간 다발 더듬는거
왜 왜
나쁜걸 원했어
아이 나보고 상담한다고 뭐 개인상담한다고
조용히 좀 있어보세요 지금 중요한 순간인데
자 상가로 평생 거기서 주식으로
네
장사를 하시거나 뭔가 이용하실게 아니라
상가 투자를 해서
나중에 재개발이 됐거나 재건축이 될 때
아파트를 받고 싶은 분은
상가를 어디 상가를 사셔야 되냐면
무조건 단지 안에 있는 상가를 사셔야 돼요
단지 안에
예를 들어서
압구정동에 가보면요
어떤 단지는 상가가 단지 안에 있고
어떤 단지는 상가가 그 대로변에 쭉 있는 상가가 있잖아요
그런데
여기서부터 이제 조합원들 간에 갈등이 있어요
아파트를 갖고 있는 사람들과 상가만 갖고 있는 사람들이
의기투합해서 다시 재건축해서 올려야 되잖아요
그런데 아파트를 가지고 있는 사람들은
아니 상가 가지고 있는 사람들에게 꼭 저렇게 한 채씩 줘야 돼
아니면 저렇게 우리가 이익을 나눠줘야 돼
그 고민이 있을 거 아닙니까
그런데 이 바깥에 대로변에 있는 상가는 어떻게도 할 수 있냐면
야 그거 빼고 우리끼리 가자 이게 강요야
그러면 대로변에 상가분들은 갑자기 낙동강 오리알이 되는 거예요
우리도 같이 올려서 한몫 잡으려고 했는데
우린 빼고 안쪽에 아파트 단지만 올리겠다
이렇게 될 수 있거든요
그래서 단지 안에 상가가 아닌 분들은
조합원 회의 이런 데 가잖아요
그러면 조용히 계세요 가만히 있어요
어르신 오셨어요 아줌마님 오셨어요
조용히 있습니다
단지 안에 정 가운데 상가가 딱 박혀있는 거 있잖아요
그 상가에 동의 없이 재건축이 되겠습니까
정 가운데 알을 박은 건데
권력이죠 권력
교수님 되게 좋은 권력이시네요
이런 거 어디서 듣겠어
그 상가 주인 가운데 상가를 가진 분은
난 어느 날짜만 회의가 되니까
그 날짜에 모이라고 하셔도 가능해요
네
근데 아무리 가운데 있어도 우투버잖아요
가만히 있어야지
저는 안 되지 저는 공격을 그냥
이게 우리 슈카 같은 분들의 애환이에요
저는 슈카를 이렇게 말씀드립니다
슈퍼 을들을 상대해야 돼요
예를 들어 건물을 가지게 되면
무슨 소리냐면 제가 친하게 지내는
영화배우나 탤런트라고 하죠
탤런트요
옛날에 탤런트 17기
이런 거 했었죠
그래서 그 방송인들 중에
정말 탑 근처에 갔던 사람들은
자기 건물 있잖아요 누구 빌딩
있지 있지
근데 그분들이 저한테 그러는 거예요
교수님 저희는요 임대료도 못 올려요
그렇겠다
그렇죠 먼저 가보시죠
얼굴이 알려져 있으니까
어느 영화배우 누가 임대료 팍팍 올리더라
이런 소리 들으면 갑질이 되는 거예요
그래서 셀럽이시잖아요
셀럽 분들은 건물을 사는 순간
슈퍼 을들에게 엄청나게 시달려
진짜 그럴 수 있겠다
그래서 제가 답을 드렸습니다
건물 사면 안 된다
차라리 상가로 돌아가라
단지 가운데 상가로 가
단지 상가
알겠습니다
네 알겠습니다
2부는 우리 박
책 주세요 중요하지
저 뭐예요
우리 1부는 박종훈 우리 팀장이
3%부터 머니코믹스까지
축가 친구들은 싹 빼고
3%에서 머니코믹스까지라는 책을 하나 내셨습니다
우리 박종훈 우리 팀장이 책 나왔다는 거 알려드리면서
우리 박종훈 교수님 다시 한 번 감사드립니다
주식은지 오늘은 여기까지였습니다
여러분 감사합니다
안녕